the President of Iran has moved to quell
mass anger over a 50 percent hike in
fuel prices Hassan rouhani said on
Sunday that the government would
compensate those who were worst affected
there's been trouble and at least a
dozen cities with buildings vandalized
and pictures of Iran's supreme leader
burned
the surprise fuel price hike
announcement came on Friday with the
government saying the revenues would
fund support for the poor meanwhile
Washington has voiced its support for
the protests a move that Tehran slammed
as hypocritical with more on this here's
RT is eager to Donna and just a heads up
his report includes our new feature a QR
code you can use to get more background
on the story now for Tehran this hike in
fuel prices is a blessing even because
they're saying that their economy is
backed into a corner it's falling apart
because of all these sanctions that the
United States has imposed against it and
these three rounds of sanctions coming
out of Washington and targeting Iran's
economy have been widely unpopular they
have drawn international criticism and
Europe for instance has been very vocal
calling in the United States not to
impose them to pull to pull back but
they have failed so far to do and you to
take any action about it and that goes
in stark contrast with what we're
hearing from Washington because despite
all the violence and all the riots on
the streets of Iran the United States
have decided to side with what they're
calling peaceful protests as I said to
the people of Iran almost a year and a
half ago the United States is with you
the United States supports the Iranian
people in the peaceful protests against
the regime that is supposed to lead them
we condemn the lethal force and severe
communications restrictions used against
demonstrators we certainly stand by the
people of Iran what you're seeing today
is them standing up to their government
saying that you know we we demand
accountability now these words have been
met with outrage in Tehran for instance
the Supreme Leader of Iran has said that
he won't allow any foreign power any
outside force to pressure his country
into economic submission people will not
be taken advantage of by outsiders who
put economic pressure on our nation
there's that of course though there's
defiance by on the part of the official
government and again they have been
taking steps to quell the anger like
with subsidies and well saying that they
reimbursed those who were who had it
worse by this fuel price hike but still
with all with the mounting pressure both
from outside and now from the inside it
certainly does look like that the
American sanctions are taking its toll
on the Iranian economy
we spoke to political scientist carve a
rsabha who says US sanctions have had a
devastating impact on the people of Iran
we are hearing increasing reports not
just from you know reliable Iranian
sources but also UN and other
international organizations about the
devastating effects of the US sanctions
on ordinary Iranians particularly with
respect to the import much needed
medicine and you know you also have the
overall economic impact that is
contributing to higher unemployment and
and so on all of which mr. Pompeo
conveniently ignores and claims to be
you know in support of the Iranian
people shedding crocodile tears for them
while imposing these harsh and savage
economic sanctions on Iran that are in
violation of the UN Security Council
resolution two two three one as well as
the international agreement that the
u.s. unilaterally walked aura
you